[MUSIC PLAYING]
LEON NICHOLLS: Hi, everyone.
NANDINI STOCKER: Hi, everybody.
Let's talk about one
of the hardest parts
of designing a spoken dialogue
between a human and a computer.
LEON NICHOLLS: How to
handle so-called "errors."
NANDINI STOCKER: Now,
before we dive in,
any good conversation starts
by knowing who's talking.
I'm Nandini Stocker.
LEON NICHOLLS: And
I'm Leon Nicholls.
NANDINI STOCKER: Leon is a
developer relations engineer
for Google Assistant apps.
LEON NICHOLLS: And Nandini
leads the conversation design
outreach for Actions on Google.
NANDINI STOCKER:
Our two teams are
responsible for most
of the resources
that you'll find on the Actions
on Google public website,
where we show developers
how they can design, build,
and deploy their apps
for the Google Assistant.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, you can
implement the techniques
we will show you
today using tools
like API.AI through-- for
fulfillment logic in your code,
or as a combination of those.
By the way, API.AI is a
tool for creating apps
for the Google Assistant.
Now, we want to help
developers create
great conversational
experiences.
The best way to do that is by
considering the design first
and working in tight
collaboration between designers
and developers, I trade on that
design within the capabilities
of the platform.
NANDINI STOCKER: Now, in
human-to-human conversations,
hesitations and corrections
happen all the time.
We just did a little
bit of it ourselves.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah, right.
NANDINI STOCKER: We
might do it again,
and we'll just blame
it on the talk.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, in
human-to-computer interactions,
they do too.
But in the form of timeouts
and recognition errors.
NANDINI STOCKER:
The difference is
that humans can take
cues from each other
to get back on
track in real time.
LEON NICHOLLS: But with
a simulated conversation,
the corrections need
to be pre-planned,
and that's not an easy task.
NANDINI STOCKER: So the only
way to course correct in advance
and still maintain a natural,
comfortable dialogue is
to plan for them as if
they were any other turn
in the conversation.
LEON NICHOLLS:
Now, here are some
of the terms we use when
talking about errors
in voice interfaces.
NANDINI STOCKER: One of the
first things to remember
is that there's a
difference between
the technical conditions and
events that trigger and respond
to these errors and all
the user scenarios that
are happening at the same time.
So any number of
things could go wrong
from the user's perspective,
so for any number of reasons.
LEON NICHOLLS:
Now, we'll show you
how keeping both of these
perspectives in mind
will be really key to your
conversation repair strategy.
NANDINI STOCKER:
Otherwise, it's pretty
easy to become
either too simplistic
or with a basic strategy of
just apologizing and asking
the same question
over and over again,
or being overly prescriptive
and formulaic in your approach.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, for
example, here's a formula that's
really common, and
often both into a lot
of tools and defaults.
NANDINI STOCKER: But this often
translates, unfortunately,
into a user having to
be asked, effectively,
for the same piece
of information,
with very little variation
3, 4, 5, or even 6 times.
LEON NICHOLLS: So that leads
to a really stiff experience,
but also a very
frustrating one for users.
NANDINI STOCKER: It's
important to note also
that user impressions
on how they're
formed in that moment when
they're going through an error
is not just about the
interaction itself
that they're going through,
it frames how people feel
as a whole about the
technology, something
that we really care
about changing.
So in fact, we've
asked people how
they feel when
recognition doesn't work,
and they have negative,
visceral reactions.
And they can't always place why.
So one of the reasons is because
people are using their voice.
Voice is one of the primary
markers of our identity.
And so it feels extra personal
when something goes wrong.
So let's dive in and
see how we can handle
these with a new paradigm.
LEON NICHOLLS: So we're going
to show you how so-called error
events could be
handled and treated,
not treated as its cases.
NANDINI STOCKER:
So instead, we're
going to leverage users'
innate expectations
about how natural conversations
are supposed to work and create
opportunities for more
meaningful interactions.
LEON NICHOLLS: So that means for
any given prompt to your user,
you have to be thinking
of all of the things that
could go wrong in that moment.
NANDINI STOCKER: But you
could still break it down
into two paths to the problem.
Either you didn't get any
input, and usually that's
because the user
didn't say anything
or because they were too quiet
to be picked up by the mic.
Or it could be
that you got input,
but you just weren't
prepared to handle it.
LEON NICHOLLS: In the
underlying system,
these two categories can be
addressed as either no inputs
or no matches.
NANDINI STOCKER: But as
part of this new paradigm,
we're not going to start there.
It pays to look at
how you can eliminate
the bulk of your errors
right off the top
with some preventative
strategies.
Now, first of all,
you want to use
the power of spoken
language to your advantage
by using well-crafted
intuitive language
in your prompt structure
and prevent errors
in the first place.
So there's a great talk
tomorrow about this
by the godfather of
voice-user interface design
James Giangola, must not miss.
LEON NICHOLLS: Otherwise, look
at how you can prevent errors
by being prepared to handle
specific types of requests,
but with more robust strategies.
NANDINI STOCKER: All right.
So your first
preventative strategy.
Be ready to provide
help in the moment.
So this usually means
being ready for--
to handle if someone asks
to hear something again,
or they express their
confusion maybe more
explicitly by saying
something like, I'm not sure,
or why do you want to know?
So let's look at how
we implement that.
Oh, I--
LEON NICHOLLS: So we need to
be able to first categorize
these responses, and then
add logic to handle them.
Some of the main
concepts in API.AI
include agents, which can be
described as natural language
understanding modules for apps.
Agents consist of intents,
which respond to particular user
inputs, and context,
which are the ways
to prioritize those
intents as they are
invoked during a conversation.
NANDINI STOCKER:
So during the many
back and forth turns
in your conversation,
each of the user responses
will map to an intent.
So like you see
here, a few key ones
are repeat, help, and quit.
LEON NICHOLLS: So here's a help
intent we created in API.AI.
NANDINI STOCKER: Notice how
it's not just the global command
help.
That's not the only
thing we're handling.
All the things a user
might say to ask for help.
How you respond to
those, of course,
will depend on your
strategy, and we'll
show you a little
bit about that.
But perhaps you
give them a hint,
or you might ask them a
follow-up question to make
sure they're ready to continue.
LEON NICHOLLS: To
make that work,
we have to add additional
intents for the user's
yes-no responses to that help
prompt, like you see here.
NANDINI STOCKER: So
OK, next immediately I
want to jump in
and find out, how
do I make it even more
relevant in that moment?
Maybe by playing
some dynamic data,
like if I want to include
a variable, for example.
LEON NICHOLLS: Sure.
So you can do that
using fulfillment.
NANDINI STOCKER: So great.
So as you can see,
in this example
is some dynamic info
about the game length
ends the question with asking
if the user wants to continue.
So now they're actually
listening for a yes-no answer
to the help question itself.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yes.
And we can dynamically
set a context
to ensure that the user's
yes-no response is handled
by the yes-no help intents.
NANDINI STOCKER: But-- so
if the user got the help
they needed when
they heard that,
and they didn't say yes
or no, but they just
answered the original question
before they asked for help.
So we wouldn't want that
to trigger an error.
Otherwise, we've sort
of defeated the purpose
to begin with.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah, right.
So we don't have to worry
about that since the other game
intents are still available, and
we'll handle it if that happens
NANDINI STOCKER: OK.
So that's Help, and
some of the questions
that come up in the
moment like repeat.
So it's a pretty big prevention
strategy out of the way.
Another very basic strategy
is to prevent frustrating
back and forth is to simply
make it easy for users to leave.
So they might need to stop
for a variety of reasons.
So being prepared
for that is not
only key to preventing errors,
but it's the right thing to do.
LEON NICHOLLS: Also, it
can be an opportunity
for reengagement.
For example, perhaps
let them know
how to come back, or pick
up where they left off,
if that's an option.
But without being annoying.
NANDINI STOCKER: So we need to--
for this, we need to create
another intent for quit, right?
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah, so start
by anticipating all the ways
the user might want to leave.
So just like Help, which
phrases you might choose
depend on the context.
NANDINI STOCKER: So for
this game example here,
you can see we've added
some custom phrases that
are appropriate for
a game, like "stop
the game," or "stop playing."
And just like Help, we
want to make the response
to user more meaningful,
and since it is a game,
I want to give them
the satisfaction
of knowing their score
where they've left off.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah, so like
we showed you with Help,
if you want to include
a variable, that's
where fulfillment comes in.
And so here you can
see our quit intent,
and we're giving the user the
score before saying goodbye.
NANDINI STOCKER: So
to give you an idea
of just how these
prevention strategies are
so critical to catching
things in context
and why that matters so
much is take a couple user
responses that really
mean something different
depending on the situation.
Take for example, I
don't know and I give up.
So in most contexts,
I don't know means--
it's just another
way of saying help.
But if you're playing a game,
that may or may not hold true.
So for example, on
the one hand, you
could have a game
where the user maybe
wants to know a little
more about the rules,
and they're not
familiar with it.
So in that case, sure, "I
don't know" means help,
like any other context.
But if it's a
familiar mental model,
like guessing game or
trivia, where the user says,
I don't know, or I
give up, it might just
mean they want the answer
so they can move on.
So in which case, it's
literally the opposite of quit.
It means, let's keep playing.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, this might
mean breaking up your help
or I don't know phrases
into different contexts.
Take two games we've
been working on.
In our number guessing game,
Number Genie, here on the left,
I give up is part
of the quit intent.
But with the trivia
game on the right,
I give up is part of
the I don't know intent.
This lets the user skip giving
an answer to the question.
NANDINI STOCKER: All right.
So another way--
LEON NICHOLLS: Oops.
NANDINI STOCKER:
Another way to prevent
errors is to use the built-in
capabilities of the platform.
So we've just announced
several of these at I/O.
LEON NICHOLLS: So our
tools and libraries
support common needed actions
called Conversation Helpers.
Now, these have been crafted to
follow best design practices,
and also to handle errors.
So we recommend
that you use these
so you don't have to
create them for yourself.
NANDINI STOCKER: All right.
So that's a lot of
deceptively simple,
but often overlooked error
prevention strategies.
Those should help your
users feel more in control
of the interaction overall.
Now let's get to the
unavoidable stuff.
LEON NICHOLLS: So
as we said earlier,
even in conversations between
humans, hesitations and repair
happen.
And as we know, speech
recognition isn't perfect.
So when it doesn't work, let's
call those errors for now.
NANDINI STOCKER: So we've got
a couple of great strategies
coming up where
we-- it'll make them
feel a little less like errors
per se, and more like new turns
in the dialog, like
we've been promising.
But before we show
you that, we think
it is important to see what it
looks like when you do start
from scratch.
LEON NICHOLLS: We'll look at
our basic errors, the no inputs
and no matches.
If you create a new
agent in API.AI,
you get two default intents
as a starting point.
The agent will start by
greeting you with the default
welcome intent, and if
you don't say anything,
it'll hit a couple of
no inputs and give up.
If you do respond,
you'll hit a no match.
NANDINI STOCKER:
So you're saying
that starting from
scratch, we have
a clean slate of only errors.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yeah.
So let's take a look
at how the default
agent handles no inputs.
We're going to play a video
of me invoking the agent
on a Google Home, and--
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Sure, here is--
LEON NICHOLLS: --not
saying anything.
- --the test version
of default action.
- Hi.
- I couldn't hear
what you've just said.
- Hi.
- I couldn't hear
what you've just said.
- Hi.
- Sorry, I can't help.
[END PLAYBACK]
NANDINI STOCKER:
And for no matches?
LEON NICHOLLS: For no
matches, well, that
would invoke the default
fallback intent, which
has a set of static responses
that are selected randomly
to respond to the user.
NANDINI STOCKER: So
anything the user says
will go to the default
fallback intent.
So let's take a look at that.
LEON NICHOLLS: OK.
Let's do that.
So we have another video, and
that force-invoking agent.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Go to default action.
- Sure.
Here is the test version
of default action.
- Hello.
- Hi.
- I missed what you said.
Say it again.
- I said, "Hi."
- Sorry.
Could you say that again?
[ELEPHANT NOISE]
I didn't get that.
- I'm trying to greet you.
- Can you say that again?
[DOG BARKING]
What was that?
- Hmm, I said, "Hi."
- I didn't get that.
Can you say it again?
[CAT MEOWING]
What was that?
- Why do I have
to repeat myself?
- Sorry, what was that?
- OK.
Goodbye.
[END PLAYBACK]
LEON NICHOLLS: OK.
So as you see, the
conversation never ends.
And if you want to
change that, you
have to add a custom intent to
handle the first user response.
NANDINI STOCKER:
Obviously, that's
no way to hold a
conversation, and we
do have a lot of built-ins
that you can add.
But it's important
to start from that
just to see how it works if
you were to start from scratch,
so that all of the things that
we show you next will start--
will make sense and connect.
LEON NICHOLLS: Otherwise, API.AI
does provide some sample data
and pre-built agents
for common use cases
that you could
start with instead.
And we're always looking at
ways to improve the tools better
by default.
NANDINI STOCKER:
So in the meantime,
we'll use that as a
baseline and explore
some more targeted solutions.
LEON NICHOLLS: OK.
Now let's take the case of
when no input is triggered.
NANDINI STOCKER:
So here remember
that the user either
actually didn't say anything,
or perhaps they got
distracted, or they
didn't hear the question.
Maybe they were listening,
they didn't understand it,
and they're just waiting to
hear what it would do next.
But it could also
be that they started
talking during the prompt and
then stopped talking right
when the mic started listening.
LEON NICHOLLS: So how
do we design for that?
NANDINI STOCKER:
Well, for no inputs,
you probably need
to consider first
if you even need the answer
to get to the next step.
So how you react
should really consider
why the user didn't respond, all
those reasons I talked about.
So it's a new turn in
the dialog, therefore
an opportunity.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now,
we have some examples
that show the difference
it makes to your wording,
depending on how
hard you want to try
and how much help you
assume the user needs.
NANDINI STOCKER: So when you
write reprompts for no input,
you should keep
them contextually.
But that doesn't
necessarily mean
repeating the exact
same question verbatim.
So maybe you just
need to reframe it
or reword it just slightly.
Or maybe you could use
that as an opportunity
to answer an unasked question.
And as far as--
and as for how many
times you want to try,
maybe you don't
want to belabor it,
and maybe you just want
to gracefully exit.
But for most cases,
you could make
use of some sort
of default pattern.
Right now the default is three,
but maybe it might change.
And find out-- just
specify what you want it
to say for each of those three.
So that's a design
strategy for no inputs.
Let's look at-- let's take
a look at how to implement.
LEON NICHOLLS: OK.
So as I mentioned earlier,
the default API.AI--
by default, API.AI handles
the no inputs for you
by using a list of
standard prompts.
Now, to change these prompts
to be domain specific,
you need to implement your
own fulfillment logic.
Now, as part of our SDK
for developing actions,
we provide a Node.js
client library
that makes it really
easy to do that.
The client library API lets you
specify the no input prompts,
like these, I didn't
hear a number.
Are you still there?
What's your guess?
NANDINI STOCKER: And the
conversation automatically ends
after that third, final prompt.
So for example,
we can stop here.
Let's play again soon.
That's how we're ending it.
Now let's look at the biggest
opportunity for creative error
handling, no matches.
LEON NICHOLLS: So just
like with no inputs,
deciding whether
you use the default
fallback for your no matches
or something more targeted
should be based on the
kind interactions you're
designing for.
NANDINI STOCKER: Again,
you need to consider
if the answer is even needed.
And if it is, you
have to consider
the user's situation and even
the sequence of questions.
And if you don't need
it, that's where you also
might decide to just move
on, pivot, or gracefully end.
LEON NICHOLLS: So that seems
like a lot to consider,
so where do we start?
NANDINI STOCKER: So
during any conversation,
it's important to stop
and look at what's
happening in each turn.
So usually, in one
turn in the dialog,
one participant is usually
the owner of the information
that the other
person is seeking.
So depending on the
context of the question
and which side of
the conversation
has that information,
the strategy will vary.
So let me show you three
examples of why this matters.
In this question, the
app knows the answer,
and the user is guessing.
But they do have a good mental
model of what's expected,
so potential errors are
at a pretty low cost.
If they don't know or they
need help, they're likely--
it's just that they don't
know how the game is played,
or maybe they want to know
how many guesses they have,
or like we said
earlier, maybe they just
want to give up and
have you tell them.
But take this question for
a reservation exchange.
Here, only the user
knows the actual answer.
But you can make some
logic assumptions,
like expecting a certain range.
And most of the time,
the answer you know
will probably be something
like 20 or fewer people.
So if the user needs help
or says, I don't know,
then the strategy you
can use depends, again,
on how critical that answer is
to continue to the next step.
So take a third example
where both sides are trying
to match on shared knowledge.
Well, both sides are supposed
to know the answer, anyway.
But especially in
this type of scenario
where it's likely some sort
of gate-keeping mechanism,
the user may or
may not know what
it is, or they want to know, why
do you need this information?
Why are you even asking me this?
And so for those
types of situations,
they're much more likely to need
in-context help to continue.
LEON NICHOLLS: So a
good strategy here
is to consider it
context by context
and offer up what might be
more useful in that moment.
NANDINI STOCKER: Exactly.
So whatever is
most likely to keep
the conversation moving
forward is what you would use
to decide on how to reprompt.
LEON NICHOLLS: So how do
we decide on the wording?
NANDINI STOCKER: I'm
glad you asked, Leon.
Well, first of all,
there's nothing wrong
with having a few generic
fallback messages.
So we call these
rapid reprompts.
Users often just need
some sort of quick signal
to indicate that you didn't
pick up what they-- exactly
what they said the first time.
However, this
strategy only works
if you are listening for the
right things to begin with.
So if you aren't catching
what they said the first time
and you don't catch it even
when they repeat themselves,
you can imagine how that gets
pretty tiresome pretty quickly.
LEON NICHOLLS: So
you need to consider
the user's situational context
for each and every question
carefully.
NANDINI STOCKER: Of course.
So it often means asking
maybe another way.
Sometimes it even means breaking
down the question into parts.
Maybe even you're
listening for both,
but you might just
ask for one, just
to move the
conversation forward.
Now, depending on how important,
again, the information
is that you're asking for, you
can also make use of escalating
detail to let users in on,
what is it you need from them,
and why are you
asking, again, to keep
the conversation moving, and
answer that unasked question.
And finally, depending
on your app's persona
and how assertive
it is, you may also
decide to be proactive and
take control of the situation.
LEON NICHOLLS: So
let's look at how
you go about implementing
some of these more
robust strategies.
First of all, it will require
implementing fulfullment
for the default fallback intent.
Now, the fulfillment logic will
then create these responses
dynamically in code.
NANDINI STOCKER: The core
implementation strategy
we recommend is to
track user progress,
lay out your reprompts,
and like they say, when
you love something, you've
got to know when to let it go.
So for the apps that
we've built together,
our code logic uses counters
and various session variables
to keep track of
the user's progress.
LEON NICHOLLS: For example,
here is the fulfillment logic
for Number Genie where
we use a counter to track
how many times the user provided
a response that was handled
by the default fallback intent.
Now, our client library
for the fulfillment logic
provides a way to store
data within a user session.
NANDINI STOCKER: You'll
then use those counters
to build a dynamic
reprompt strategy,
using both a combination of
generic fallback sometimes
and context-sensitive
approaches, like we
talked about earlier.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, in API.AI,
the default fallback intent
can be a starting point with a
minimum set of basic reprompts.
Here we have a set of
default rapid reprompts
that just provide a
catch-all anywhere,
and we'll reprompt the user
to say their response again.
NANDINI STOCKER: From there,
you can change those default
to suit your app.
So you might just want
to add more to that list,
and add a few different
rapid reprompts.
LEON NICHOLLS: The
agent will then randomly
select from your prompts
whenever a no match
event is triggered.
NANDINI STOCKER:
But like we said,
sometimes you might want to
pivot and ask the question
a little differently, though.
So a rapid reprompt
might not be enough.
LEON NICHOLLS: So
in this instance,
for example, we
created a game, and we
wanted to use the
default handler
to ask a yes-no question,
whether the user was
done playing.
It's still generic
and catch-all,
but we've customized it to
fit the strategy of our game.
NANDINI STOCKER: But to
get users back on track,
you actually might want your
reprompt to not be generic.
So you want to reprompt
with a lot more context,
like some of those
examples we showed you.
LEON NICHOLLS: So to
plan for the logic needed
to implement the
context-sensitive reprompts,
it really helps to see them
mapped out ahead of time.
in some user journeys
and sample dialogs first.
For example, when I walk through
the journeys Nandini wrote
for Number Genie, they drove
what variables and states
needed to be tracked in
the app fulfillment logic.
NANDINI STOCKER:
And each time you
reprompt, look for opportunities
to add some variability
or reframe the question.
So this will lend more
naturalness to the dialog
and help users sometimes
not even realize they are
experiencing an error per se.
LEON NICHOLLS: So to reframe
the question you asked,
we can use a feature in API.AI
that allows you to tag intents
with labels called context.
Here is one that is tagged
with the GetTime context.
NANDINI STOCKER: And this
is the fulfillment logic
with the default fallback
intent for the GetTime context
and what it looks like.
LEON NICHOLLS: So these can
also be statically assigned
in API.AI's web GUI
for each intent.
For example, here's
a list of intents
we designed for a trivia game.
Notice all the
expected user responses
we handle using many different
things intents, including help,
quit, and restart.
NANDINI STOCKER: Now,
let's say you wanted
to combine both strategies.
We can show you how to
implement both together
in a more escalating
reprompt strategy.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now,
from experience
we know that rapid
reprompts work.
But we also know, depending
on the user scenario,
we might want to pivot
off to another error.
NANDINI STOCKER: So to do that,
you'll need to keep a counter
and increase it every
time the user response
is handled by that
fallback intent.
LEON NICHOLLS: So here's
the fulfillment logic
for the default fallback
intent for our trivia game.
Notice how we use a counter that
is stored in the session data.
NANDINI STOCKER: For the first
time the intent is invoked,
we provide a rapid reprompt
by using the client
library ask function.
And for the second
time, we respond
with a fallback response.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now,
obviously, that escalation
shouldn't go on forever.
NANDINI STOCKER: When
it comes to no matches,
know when to give up.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, after
you've tried a couple of times,
once the counter goes
above a threshold,
bow out of the
conversation gracefully.
NANDINI STOCKER: Now,
how you word that,
again, precisely,
depends on your persona.
LEON NICHOLLS: So back
to the trivia game
default fallback intent handler.
When the user response triggers
the intent for the third time,
we provide a fallback prompt,
and then end the conversation
by using the client
library tell function.
NANDINI STOCKER:
However, of course,
if the conversation
with the user
recovers and another
intent is invoked,
like we talked about
earlier, if they actually
answer the question, then it's
not a default fallback intent.
Then we reset that
counter value.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, those
were just the basics.
NANDINI STOCKER:
Just the basics.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yep.
So from here, you
can find lots of ways
to step up your conversation
repair game even more.
NANDINI STOCKER: I feel like--
yeah-- but wait, there's more.
So one way is to
inherently disguise errors.
So by adding naturalness
and variability to make
the entire conversation
feel more engaging.
So the key is that
it doesn't just
apply to your error prompts,
but all the other prompts
everywhere else.
LEON NICHOLLS: So this
is one of the many ways
that designing with a particular
persona in mind for your app
comes in really handy.
NANDINI STOCKER: So we keep
hinting at this persona,
so we'll show you one
example of what we mean.
So for example, in the trivia
game we've been working on,
we use a teacher persona.
His name is Mr.
Montgomery, which
we-- he would be the
type of character that
is super encouraging, and
he really wants you-- you
got this.
That's his-- you know,
he's a teacher, right?
LEON NICHOLLS: So
to give you an idea,
our teacher has over
50 ways of saying,
you got the answer right.
NANDINI STOCKER: And over
30 ways to prop you up
if you got it wrong.
Also, again, this is
stepping up your game.
Use threading techniques.
So in spoken dialogue
between humans,
elements of a conversation
are woven together
in a coherent thread.
And that includes both
context and the way
the conversation
evolves over time.
So this type of
threading, it helps
us keep track of that
conversational flow.
LEON NICHOLLS:
Now, you would have
to write the prompts that
thread together well,
but pragmatically
speaking, you need
to support that flow in
some underlying framework.
And that will use tracking,
context, and counters, just
like we've talked about before.
NANDINI STOCKER: So to support
variability in threading,
you could build a robust list
of prompts and randomize them.
LEON NICHOLLS: And you can scale
that to any number of prompts
without changing the code.
NANDINI STOCKER: If you
can randomize three,
you can randomize 103.
LEON NICHOLLS: Yep.
NANDINI STOCKER:
The prompts can also
be concatenated to create a
large number of permutations.
LEON NICHOLLS: And you
can add dynamic value
by formatting your
prompts with variables
that are replaced at runtime.
NANDINI STOCKER: And
to prevent the user
from hearing the same
prompts and sequence,
you can remember which
prompts you've played,
and avoid them when
you're randomly
picking next from the list.
LEON NICHOLLS: You can also
track the number of errors
and in what sequence they occur.
NANDINI STOCKER: Finally,
after you've deployed your app,
your error-handling
approach doesn't stop there.
So you should check in with
what your users are doing,
and you can adjust your
strategy, if needed.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now, API.AI
provides a training feature,
which allows you to track
which user responses are not
being met by intent.
Now, this feedback could be
used to expand your support
for the user queries.
It can also give you hints
on what new intents might
need to be added to your app.
NANDINI STOCKER: So
one powerful notion
to remember is that users who
are not encountering errors
should feel the benefit
of progressing through,
so that when an
error is encountered,
they don't feel derailed.
So also, it's proven
that reminding
them how far they've gotten or
that they don't how far to go
will help them
get back on track.
OK.
That's enough
strategies for now.
Let's look at these in action.
LEON NICHOLLS: OK.
So we're going to show you a
demo of Number Genie, which
we designed and built together.
And it's available as
a sample on our site.
NANDINI STOCKER: So we
chose a number guessing game
because we felt like
you guys as developers,
you could mentally map
a number guessing game.
And you can sort of picture
some of the concepts
we've been talking about.
So we've built-in a
hidden developer mode.
This game is public.
You're welcome to try this out.
And I'm going to
pray to the demo gods
that they don't smite me here.
But there's a hidden
developer mode
in which we can set the number
that the genie is thinking of.
And we're going to
guess around it, so
that you can hear
some of the strategies
that we talked about.
All right.
OK.
Hey, Google.
Let's talk to Number
Genie about 21.
SPEAKER 1: Sure.
Here's Number Genie.
SPEAKER 2: Welcome
back to Number Genie.
I'm thinking of a
number from 0 to 100.
What's your first guess?
NANDINI STOCKER: 50.
SPEAKER 2: It's lower than 50.
Have another guess.
NANDINI STOCKER: Uh, 0.
SPEAKER 2: I see
what you did there.
But no, it's higher than 0.
NANDINI STOCKER: 30.
SPEAKER 2: I didn't
hear a number.
NANDINI STOCKER: 30.
SPEAKER 2: You're getting warm.
It's lower than 30.
Have another guess.
NANDINI STOCKER: 17.
SPEAKER 2: It's so
close, but not quite.
NANDINI STOCKER: 19.
SPEAKER 2: It's higher than 19.
What's your next guess?
NANDINI STOCKER: 20.
SPEAKER 2: Are you done
playing Number Genie?
NANDINI STOCKER: No.
SPEAKER 2: Great.
What's your next guess?
NANDINI STOCKER: 21.
[CHIMES]
SPEAKER 2: Well done.
[APPLAUSE]
It is indeed 21.
Want to play again?
NANDINI STOCKER: No thanks.
LEON NICHOLLS: OK.
So now, it's really interesting
to see the interaction.
But you know, a number guessing
game is deceptively simple.
If you just think
about it, there's
comparing a number and a guess.
But it can be designed to be
delightful by adding layers
of tracking in the game logic.
NANDINI STOCKER: So let's
look real quick under the hood
at the fulfillment
logic of Number Genie.
LEON NICHOLLS:
Now, we track a lot
of things in the conversation.
Notice that we use a
counter for fallbacks.
NANDINI STOCKER: We also
track the number of guesses,
the value of the previous
guess, and how many times
the user gives the same answer.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now,
we also consider
how far away the user's
guess is from the answer.
NANDINI STOCKER:
As the user gets
closer to the answer, in
which the demo didn't work,
we provide rapid reprompts
and encouraging sounds.
So try it out
yourself, and you'll
see there's a few
hidden gems in there,
and the way it reprompts.
And it throws in
a few sounds when
you're getting a little
closer, a little far away.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now,
we also remember
if we gave the user a hint in
what direction the answer is.
NANDINI STOCKER: And
we changed the prompts
and tracked when the user
followed or ignored our hints.
Be sure to try that out too.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now,
here you can see
some of the prompts
we use in the game.
We dynamically provide values
for the variable characters
in the prompts based on the
user input and the game state.
NANDINI STOCKER: So
I hope we've shown
you a foundation of building
your conversation repair
strategy.
We talked a little bit about
the types of error events
to plan for, how to use
built-ins and other existing
tool features to
implement in your design,
and prevent the bulk of errors
by anticipating and tracking
user progress in context.
LEON NICHOLLS: But the
key to any strategy
for creating a
conversational experience,
especially for when
things go wrong,
is to step back, and look
at the user's situation.
NANDINI STOCKER:
Don't create dead ends
when something didn't work.
So remember, it doesn't have
to be treated as an error.
LEON NICHOLLS: Now,
there are more docs
and resources available on our
site, including white papers
and a design checklist.
NANDINI STOCKER: Which includes
an entire list of conversation
repair check items.
Also, take a look at
the sample apps that we
have open source in GitHub.
LEON NICHOLLS: There's
also a lot more talks
about conversation
design tomorrow, as well
as Office Hours, so you can
talk to some of our teams.
And because we think some
of the best strategies
will come from you,
we want to hear all
about what you come up with.
NANDINI STOCKER: So
as you saw yesterday,
we announced the Actions on
Google Developer Challenge.
We had a little part in that.
Remember that when
you're creating yours
that any winning app probably
will have a killer conversation
repair strategy at
its core, right?
LEON NICHOLLS: And we can't
wait to see what you create.
NANDINI STOCKER: Thank you.
LEON NICHOLLS: Thanks.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]